don't you just love it when two of your
favorite things come together enjoy the
walking dead pool
[Music]
it sorry I'm late I was rounding up all
the gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again kiss me like you missed me read
what in the ass
you're living the dreams DP
what in the ass my name's cable I'm here
for the kid
but the kid
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be can you do Valentin Cable
kill Russell but I can't do this alone
we're gonna form a super duper group
it's time to get back on LinkedIn
I am letting the cable kill Russell
we're gonna form a super duper group our
group will be forward-thinking gender
neutral we will be known as x-force a
little derivatives you're absolutely
right don't call it a comeback
you want to fight for what's right
sometimes you have to fight dirty money
that is why the man bun is just a
millennial mullet hey everybody its
charlie we got a whole bunch of new
Deadpool to break down I posted a video
this morning that for some reason it got
blocked by Fox so this is just like a
small edit I just had to remove a little
bit of footage but is basically Deadpool
recruiting x-force
with a notable inclusion where we learn
who Julian Dennison is playing so no
worrys funny that I would make a video
about Avengers scenes being banned than
to have some Deadpool stuff banned to so
what a coincidence they reveal who
Julian Denison's character is and it's
not someone I expected but it makes
sense when I explain it because you have
cables so you wonder if they're gonna be
doing any strife stuff in the future
with the x-force movie like all this
Deadpool to stuff is leading up to
x-force that's why they're building the
x-force team in this movie so that they
can just start with them already being a
team when we get to that x-force movie
so if you're finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos we're just getting started
with Deadpool - infinity war is coming
in a couple weeks the main reason why
they dropped this though isn't to tell
you who the villain is it's just to let
you know the tickets are on sale
so when Deadpool says I'm not letting
cable kill Russell a lot of people like
are they talking about shattered star
because shatter star's name is Russell
no he's not talking about him he's
talking about the kid russell collins is
the name of fire fist in the comics he
has pyrokinesis just like julian
Denison's character so that's what I
think that he's referring to he's also a
recurring character during a lot of
these associated Deadpool Cable comics
like New Mutants exterminators x-factor
x-factor is big because that gets into
stripes stuff I don't think they're
gonna do an X Factor movie I think
they'll do X Factor storylines within
the x-force movies but I don't think
you're gonna see like a billion
different Deadpool spin-offs like you'll
see Deadpool you'll see x-force movies
and it's probably going to be in because
New Mutants is kind of its own separate
franchise unless they change some things
to actually connect at some of these
other movies but rusty is just a normal
mutant with pyrokinesis whose parents
wound up dying so he wound up in the
care of other people he got tied up in a
bunch of different organizations in
wound up being killed during a big
asteroid
magnito story so obviously the movies
aren't gonna be doing that kind of stuff
which is why I think this is gonna be an
original story with just some
similarities to cable Deadpool strife
x-factor storylines but the big cable
crossover point of reference is as he
was eventually brainwashed to become
part of Strife's Mutant Liberation Front
he sent them to go steal an artifact
from a museum cable showed up wound up
killing most of the brainwashed Mutant
Liberation Front people fire fist
managed to crawl away eventually got D
program by Magneto like remember how the
Winter Soldier got D programmed by Shuri
during the Black Panther movie magneto
did the same thing for fire fist and
then they went to asteroid M eventually
there was this really crazy story that
was sort of a spin-off from Age of
Apocalypse where they found Holocaust
whose apocalypse is son with one of his
horsemen he wound up killing most of
those people in asteroid M including
buyer fist so I'm not expecting them to
do any of that stuff in the movie but
the way these movies wind up using those
big characters and those big storylines
like Age of Apocalypse or Days of Future
past is that there's always some
post-apocalyptic future where everything
has gone horribly wrong cable usually
time travels back into the past to try
and stop that so because Rusty's
character winds up becoming a leader in
these organizations in the future he
might wind up getting brainwashed in
some future timeline by strife and doing
all these terrible things and that's why
cables coming back to kill him but we
finally got confirmation that he's not
some young version of black Tom Cassidy
because a lot of people wondered if that
was gonna be Jack Casey's character then
there were reports that during the
reshoots they just completely cut that
character out the writer debunked that
so they're like no we didn't cut that
character out so whatever Jack Cassey
was doing in the movie if he still is
playing black Tom Cassidy based on what
the writer said it sounds like he's
still in the movie but I don't think
that he's meant to be the big main
villain I think the cable is supposed to
be the villain of this movie even though
technically he's not a villain I think
that they're just gonna fight their way
across most of this movie then they'll
find out what they're really doing come
together and you'll find out who the
real big villain is then that'll all
play out over the x-force movies so even
though x-force is sort of a different
franchise technically it's like the
third Deadpool movie it all we know
right now is that they're calling it
x-force I don't know if they're gonna
call it Deadpool
x-force or literally the movie will just
be called x-force a lot of times you
don't find out about that to the last
minute it's like the Avengers for title
thing you know it's gonna be called
Avengers something but they hold the
title back in case they want to change
their mind or it's a big spoiler but
here's my question for you guys even if
it's been a long time since you read a
lot of these deep x-men cuts like
exterminators or x-factor what do you
want them to do with the strife
character because it's a pretty crazy
storyline even getting into cable
time-travel stuff like the closest we've
gotten to time-travel in the Marvel
Universe is Days of Future past and even
then they sort of did it by sending
Wolverines consciousness back into the
past
he didn't physically time-travel so
we've done that but cable himself
physically time travels into the past so
it's a completely different type of
technology in the first deadpool movie
was like barely in x-men movie you deal
with the Weapon X offshoot Ajax who are
creating mutants to sell on the black
market is about as grounded as you can
get next to a Logan movie Logan is still
probably the most grounded of all the
superhero movies the last couple of
years but when you get into this crazy
x-force x-factor cable strife
time-travel stuff it just goes off the
rails so that's why I'm expecting
whatever the movie does with those
characters to be much much simpler and
easier to swallow than what you saw in
the comics good example over an infinity
warp we have the Infinity stones you can
do anything
shape reality to your will how crazy do
you want these movies to get with some
of those stories I think with a movie
like infinity war you kind of go into it
knowing what you're going to get based
on the way they marketed it but because
we haven't seen too much of the Deadpool
movie you just not sure exactly what's
gonna be happening other than cable
showing up to kill a kid the Deadpool
tries to protect we as comic book fans
know that there's a time-travel aspect
of this because cables from the future
he's the son of Cyclops and Madeleine
Pryor but that also gets into some
really weird storylines and we have all
this Dark Phoenix stuff so it starts to
spiral out of control
how crazy do you want them to get with
x-force do you want it to feel more like
the first Deadpool movie or do you want
them to go full infinity war and just
completely embrace all that craziness I
think we'll get a better sense for what
they're doing with these characters as
we see more marketing they just haven't
really started doing that yet so
you know maybe like the next month or
two we'll start seeing some more footage
and figure it out click here to learn
about some of the scenes from infinity
war being banned in countries and click
here for that other Deadpool trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]